what's up everybody it's Jaylen green
brought to you by Google pixel I'm here
on my
stylist and we getting ready for the
gq's man of the year
party who is
that you expecting somebody
no jayen what up ji I heard just going
to the party you know I know you need a
stylist so best of the best since you
here let's get in here man so this is
Modi men of the year you got to go with
something formal but flashy at the same
time what's the vibe for theight I say I
wear a lot of black Gothic calm calm and
a little loud you know I might put some
colors in calm and
Loud let me try this on right here oo I
like
[Music]
this got it I'mma say this for
later I got this try that out now this
is it yeah we did it man all right you
got your fit on I'm about to put mine on
oh you coming with me yeah okay bet so
this is the final fit we see how at the
party in the red car